lo que haremos en este vídeo es pensar
cómo sumar números mixtos ahora sólo
recordemos lo que es un número mixto es
algo así como tres y dos octavos se
llama mixto por la forma en que
representamos este número hay un número
entero el 3 y luego otra parte es una
fracción dos octavos pero el número es
tres y dos octavos
así que pensemos cómo podríamos sumar
tres y dos octavos más cinco y tres
octavos pausa este vídeo y trata de
resolverlo antes de trabajar juntos en
esto muy bien hagámoslo juntos hay un
par de maneras en que podríamos abordar
esto es posible que reconozcas que tres
y dos octavos es lo mismo que tres más
dos octavos y cinco y tres octavos es lo
mismo que cinco más tres octavos y si
sumamos estas dos cosas en realidad
estamos sumando estas cuatro cosas no
importa el orden en que las comemos así
que podríamos ver esto como tres más
cinco más dos octavos más tres octavos
fíjate que es lo mismo
estoy cambiando el orden en el que
estamos sumando ahora cuánto es 353
enteros más cinco enteros es igual a
ocho y cuando esos octavos más tres
octavos bueno si tengo dos de algo en
este caso octavos y sumó tres más de ese
algo en este caso octavos
voy a tener cinco de ese algo en este
caso cinco octavos así que serán 85
octavos que podemos expresar como un
número mixto es igual a ocho y cinco
octavos
ahora hay personas que resuelven esto de
otras formas puede que veas que escriben
tres más dos octavos y luego justo
debajo de eso el cinco en la posición de
las unidades o de los números enteros
solo hay una posición en estos números
enteros
entonces escribirán cinco justo debajo
del tres y luego la fracción le
escribirán justo debajo de la fracción
tres octavos y luego podemos sumar
verticalmente donde primero podemos ver
la parte fraccional dos octavos más tres
octavos es igual a cinco octavos
35 es igual a 8 y si sumas estos 2 85
octavos obtienes 8 y 5 octavos son
diferentes formas de abordarlo pero
espero que te sientas cómodo con la suma
de números mixtos